les autobots et squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve fois la suite d' alien
désolation souvenez vous on était
évidemment j'ai avancé un tout petit peu
dans l'espoir de trouver un point de
sauvegarde que je n'ai pas trouvé échec
on venait de voir les deux voulaient
attention il s'est levé pour nous voyez
vous finalement c'est pour vous dire
bonjour on était la volaille et on
pouvait pas passer par là donc
ripley avait dit il doit y avoir un
autre chemin effectivement il y avait un
autre chemin c'est pas magnifique ça
sans déconner et l'autre chemin passe
par ce conduit il se passe quelque chose
là bas
ian young qui s'embrouillent à quelqu'un
qui use et moi à cinématique je
rétablisse les communications portée oui
si vous montrer des signes d'hystérie
recul et je vous préviens à une solution
à l'amiable
non ils vont se défoncer au nom des
enfants il va mourir je vous le tuer ont
évolué tu es bon tu es au nom
bonne journée en plus il a dit
tranquillement ou quoi comme si le matin
on souhaitait aux jeunes bonne journée à
11 ans avec cbs qu'on avait vu dans
l'épisode 2 ou chez plus combien j'avais
dit que les android et les villans et
c'est exactement ce qui se passe on est
bien dans le boudin la loa d'air va nous
être très utile à obtenir l'accès à
l'ascenseur éviter la détection j'ai
l'impression une belle petite pression 1
comme la bière la vie à pression allez
on continue ni vu ni connu
on va mettre ça sur les excuses du
stress non non nous tuera saharien klein
doit aller là bas à gauche ou non un et
nous repérer et antibes à la personne oh
mais non ils sont là mais plus discret
mais elle est l'hôte il est là c'est là
à les appeler l'ascenseur oh [ __ ] la
personne allez j'ai fait des appels de
phares l'ascenseur il c'est bon au
revoir c'est bon on a réussi alors
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant au nom
mais va y avoir dix fois plus d'android
là où je suis sûr on est vraiment dans
le boudin oh là là oh yes alors y est
non
toutes les communications au nom on peut
pas communiquer manquait plus que ça
doit y avoir un moyen de contacter
quelqu'un la station on va essayer de
passer là dedans trouver un autre
terminal des communications faut que
j'aille là alors que je suis là mais ça
va pas alors là je vous le dis là je
vous le dis il va falloir faire va
falloir faire appel aux grenades
aveuglantes aux fumigènes et à
l'émetteur de son sinon on va partir sur
un bon gros décès là il y en a ou pas oh
là là bas à droite de la droite
honte à barèges personnes et là ça
marche et ça marche et ça a marché
oh non non non non non non non comment
est à cela mais c'est juste pour vous
dire bonjour à vous écrase a été d'un
mec moi je vous tire dessus
c'est comme ça quoi c'est pas cool aïe
ça fait mal mais je t'aime j'ajuste le
chemin chez qu'on va mourir mais juste
un chemin potable ou à les séparer je
dois aller le pet nous avons besoin
d'être toute urgence répondait je vous
en prie je comprends rien à ce qui se
passe je cours y en a ah oui non mais
laissez moi on veut un cache cache ou
quoi je vous invite tous vous êtes tous
aveugles et je suis trop fort je viens
gâché tout convertir y juste pour vous
faire plaisir c'est là on y est oui oh
j'ai réussi on a réussi à l'aps vous
avez vivant qui série plaît ça lui plaît
on s'inquiétait des sorties ou êtes-vous
waimes actuellement trois jours de soins
entendu samuel sar lalla elle a pris ici
cet endroit a été barricadée par six
jeunes leur [ __ ] tu android sont en
train de faire un massage c'est clair
j'en suis je suppose que six en a une
conception différente des synthétiques
il ya autre chose
une créature énorme et meurtrier en
neuvième
un alien une forme de vie est une espèce
inconnue une sorte d'organisme mayenne 1
manière extrêmement dangereux taylor en
hongrie lors de la traversée à dépressif
quel est son état
[ __ ] j'arrive d'accord j'arrive
bah ouais mais j'ai pu partir et moi je
pensais mourir retourné par six hommes
comme ceux s'échappe et non un comme lui
qui est là pour nous aider à les envoyer
comme souper de choper c'est m je sais
que vous êtes par là non on se balade de
convier ans conduit c'est génial là il
faut qu'on tourne au dessus de
communication ça ne marchait pas pour
ensuite en fait on revient carrément en
arrière quoi pour les rejoindre nos
potes mais sauf que bien évidemment il
ya des [ __ ] d'android sur notre route
on a beau avoir un revolver ça les
chatouilles à 1 c'est comme si je fais
avec une plume se casser vos votes forme
de piège et la pression un truc de
dingue la merde
oh là là je n'ai même pas vu cette
chance que j'ai eue non non
si tout va bien on va faire un nom avec
ton copain moi je me casse pièce on a
réussi on s'en bat les steaks ont fait
la fête avec toi tu revolver alors je
sauvegarde vite fait merci sauvegarde
on sent mal au pl oui où on a réussi
j'avais la pression [ __ ] c'est
incroyable ah j'étais quand même au cas
où il ya un an et demi de l'ascension
avec moi mais qu'on ne le verrait pas
non c'est bon c'est bien là que de balle
et c'est bien là que je devais aller
le chemin est long et périlleux mais il
ne fait arriveront parce que nous sommes
plus forts que tu es dans une petite
pensée pour hugues en passant qui n'a
pas eu la chance que nous avons c'est
dommage voilà c'est triste finalement
j'aurais préféré qu'il finisse sa
carrière dans une fromagerie à fabriquer
du bon cantal pour nous chères français
là on est revenus là on a commencé cette
vidéo je tiens à le dire
si vous êtes à un moyen mec là dans
l'accueil boîte
what what c'est de la base d'al c'est du
sort d'alien mais fort hood là bas vous
j'en sais rien je me bas rhin il ya des
bruits yale c'est quoi ce bruit donc on
peut gagner un prix comme ça au fond ce
câble n'y a pas la lienne ya la mienne
qui est au dessus de nous vous
l'entendez [ __ ] je sauvegarde occase
ou alors est-ce qu'on va réussir à
prendre ce véhicule de transport pour
rejoindre nos potes place ce serait bien
ce serait une chance formidable
finalement un an pour faire tout ce
chemin en mai mais qu en fait ils vont
nous refaire revenir carrément jusqu'au
menu principal du jeu je pense
on est tous tendus à l'heure qu'il est
mesdames et messieurs aubin s'est barré
battant à quel moment on est tendu
ah non mais non il est là je suis juste
aveugle ya la lienne ya la lienne
regardez-moi ça il ya la lienne au
dessus mais il peut pas bouffer cet
androïde la vieille manon olive de la
chair fraîche s'il veut finalement du
bon steak haché 1
ça n'intéresse pas lui du semblant
dégueulasse on est passé merde c'est
fermé non oui allez autant de monde
situation ça fait plaisir à tout moment
j'ai tellement peur de me faire griller
[ __ ] c'est affreux sérieusement à les
revendre à ripley s'il vous plaît un
conseil du fait du bodybuilding
maintenant tu vas pas nous mentir à
léopold de joplin des gens de premier
réflexe sûr qu'ils sont détectés heures
ils ont pris ma fille si vous m'entendez
répondait je vous en prie on est sur le
pont de la salle des machines je fais ce
que je peux rats j'ai moi même des amis
et une famille finalement vous allez
tous vous détendre penser qu'il va nous
voir si on passe moi je pense que oui on
ferme les yeux on y va au quai s'est
passé ouais mais là vous verrez c'est
par là donc j'ai beau être passé sert à
rien il est juste là regarder le tout va
bien
non non non tu dégage tu me touches pas
un robot dégueulasse droite puis gauche
hockey balle et l'ascenseur et je me
tais adios amigos aa oui on avait aussi
les gens on s'appuie bien fort voilà un
[ __ ] et c'était plein d'émotion cette
partie là du gameplay alors emprunté le
transit vers la tour 101
ok on y va tout de suite ya aucun
problème ça me regarde et on se retrouve
carrément dans la salle où oui à cette
bonne femme qui était là que vous avez
tiré dessus la barre bref il ya la
lienne wata phoques mais pas toi crâne
chauve [ __ ] vadrouille de merde [ __ ]
ah non non non non non dites moi c'est à
sauvegarder automatiquement quand on
arrivait dans l'ascenseur et que tu nous
a rattrapés par la cheville il a même
cassé la petite chaînette qu'on avait
lâché vous savez les filles sur l'appel
gens souvent une petite chaînette à la
cheville pour faire mignon non non non
alors foiré n'a rarement vu des
créatures aussi aux le petit bug mais
c'est beau ça regardait professionnelle
dans le mime quand même hein vous le
dire vraiment j'ai vu quelqu'un aussi
bien me mais un regard des rôles à la
taz effet d'une mine pendant un an mais
là c'est un autre niveau 1
ok nous revoilà la lie à la lienne faut
faire super gaffe ou et le point de
sauvegarde nulle part je passe tout ça
sans faire le moindre bruit assez lui
c'est lui là qui est par terre qui nous
a fait chier on va l'esquivé il est
juste à côté de nous il échoue au regard
des passe au dessus de nous et tout un
yes du coup j'ai mis au courant je m'en
bats les c est qu on a réussi messieurs
dames on ne peut être trop content à
séparer deux fois les voiles à faire la
tournée med
regardez un peu dans quel état se
retrouve mes cheveux à cause d'eux au
canard au ps au nom allait mal elle
aimait gamal c'est bien moi merde à
temps mais que tu ne pousses pas comme
ça un [ __ ] pas parce que tu as des
cheveux tu peux te la péter hill buffon
il faut un traitement ils sont mais
qu'elle est proche mais je ne voulais
pas la laisser seule je les sens que je
peux trouver rester avec elle reste avec
moi taylor ils peuvent aller chercher de
l'aide
ah bien sûr c'est toujours ip qui s'y
colle toute manière à elle reste pas
faire des calinous alo'o de sa non c'est
pas possible
alors on y va d'un petit tripp les
allées on sort les doigts des fesses
voilà on est l'eau waouh
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe dans les volets s'ouvrent ah c'est
beau comme ça nous regarde et on dira un
lever de soleil le matin la prairie
comme ça ouais carrément je cherche un
médecin m'entendez eh ben on entend mois
entend moi j'ai dit oh merci mon gars
montez vous vers l'ascenseur va c'est
génial et on se fait des amis en plus
c'est un nouvel opus déception la ccim
désolation entrer dans la maison
médicale san cristobal en plat on est
arrivé à destination avec deux jambes en
moins mais à destination quand même bon
jour mais pas vraiment notre meilleur
jour oui je vois pour une fois que ça on
croise quelqu'un que pas forcément de
leur but et replay
je cherche un médecin famille a besoin
de matériel médical va nous aider ou 10
personnes l'hôpital ça marche noire max
demi alors je retrouve le code de
l'ascenseur de service et ils peuvent
guider
ok donc j'allais dans le bureau de
morlaix bochum a trouvé son bureau alors
où est donc à aller [ __ ] et en équipe
vous pensez pas aux dégâts tous les deux
je sais pas trop où on va bien voir au
[ __ ] [ __ ] ya la lienne ça pue la
liane ça pue la lienne ceux qui
souffraient de troubles d'adaptation
l'espace lointain les cas tragique
oui tu vois jusqu'où allait plus tard je
m'en foutais à doha selon ce couloir et
ben voila voila tu me dis les choses
comme ça un peu gaffe à des messages
cryptés la dina coloriage d'un enfants
de cp teese est le syntoniseur ces
parties chaudes accepte alors qu'est ce
qu'on a dans ce bureau vous y êtes si le
bureau de mort les échos d'accès
devraient quelque part ici pourquoi pas
dans l'écho de ce squelette un qui est
mon seul en or [ __ ] j'ai tué mon seul
ami nickel oui c'est 17 02 allait garder
toujours sur lui trouver le hockey il va
être complètement décédé 17 02 ça marche
je sais comment ce qu'ils en attendant
restez concentrés sur la recherche de la
carte d'accès mais amenait qu elle est
juste un alien qui me pousse chasser
mais qui me fait bon on reste calme
ah on mange même un curly si besoin
sortons de cette pièce oh [ __ ] mais je
suis content si je suis parti sur mon
gars ça sent la lienne l'aliène qui fait
du strip tease soit j'ai oh oh oh non
non
vous l'avez vu comme moi et on va mourir
et sexy aliens comment ça va à regarder
il est là et on le voit bien il posait
il fait du pc à non plus maintenant je
me cachais adonnant à densité des
tiroirs s'être compliqué peut-être si je
me couper en petits morceaux et encore
[Applaudissements]
je m'en remets j'aimerais juste
sauvegarde et j'aimerais juste
sauvegarder yes
oui oui [ __ ] on est des pros allez
maintenant avec des petit fils daniau la
de poulet même merde c'était quoi
17 40 je crois au jeu on est à l'abri de
tout deux choses négatives
bonjour où est cette femme là que je
prenne sa carte et que je me tire
pouilles et la salle de tourner deux
docteurs morlaix à 26 c il était dans la
chambre à 26 ou la chambre à 26 excusez
moi s'il vous plaît ne me dites pas que
la ligne il peut se ramener un doit se
taper le code c'est tout 17 02 il doit
le taper aussi je l'entends à les steaks
hachés regardez il est juste à côté
regardez les tekken a explosé là alors
c'est bien parce qu'on pourra faire un
procès aux fabricants et gagner un max
d'argent mais en attendant ça va péter
on va mourir c'est par là aulas comme
aussonne las chicas non mais regardez la
zone quoi la journée juste immense et
bien évidemment dans cette [ __ ] vous
devez voir au [ __ ] au regard d inciter
laquelle à 27 wavin je suis tombé je lis
un truc et je te b c'était le 26 ou le
je crois que c'est là 27 celle là ou
alors c'est elle a 26 ans et rien de ce
qui se passe là
à ta ble ment pourquoi l'ana fumée j'ai
retiré après fixation l'air mais je les
remets tout de suite on se lève on le
voit moi je vous le dis oh il arrive on
ne bouge plus oh oui oui vas-y va
rentrer il arrive à les reconquérir
c'est bon nous a pas trouvé bon au
niveau non il faut y aller quoi c'est
maintenant ou jamais on est morts n'ont
jamais fumé j'ai fait mes cheveux méchés
[ __ ] mais c'est méga dur quoi regarder
c'est la havane tôt 6 s'est jamais les
ont en plus ménard et ses blagues un peu
vite que toi mon gars des champions
d'athlétisme
ah ça c'est pas mon pénis l'on sache car
dire celles que d'alien on est pas au
delà les gens c'est déjà fin de cet
épisode sur aliens désolé j'ai pas
réussi à passer ça mais là ça fait une
heure et quelques que je joue il est
temps d'arrêter et de faire le montage
pourquoi pour que vous puissiez regarder
cette vidéo finalement chez soi que
c'était besoin de vous a plu c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas aimer les vidéos comme
d'habitude moi je trouve qu'il ya plus
en plus de pression qui s'instaure plus
en plus d'actions et tout s'est vraiment
flippant bien sûr tout bientôt pour la
suite
un tiens tout le monde pour samedi soir
pis
[Musique]